qu'un
fais-le
Que tout le monde nous reconnaissait comme ça
Si quelqu'un vient de l'extérieur, alors d'abord vos relations
Comment se fait-il qu'il ait deux fréquences ?
Sinon ils vont en abuser crêpe
Ensuite, ils me taquinent avec des noms différents.
Cela s'est fait petit à petit et puis l'amitié s'est développée.
Si vous le ramenez lentement à ce stade, vous le reconnaîtrez.
Puis il est devenu un nom distinct comme Rohit.
De qui vais-je reconnaître alors ?
[musique]
piller
fais-le
Que les ruraux bénéficieront d'installations complètes dans le village
Si nous y parvenons, nous irons aussi aux Jeux olympiques et
Apportera la gloire à notre village en remportant une médaille
Donc
fais-le
Est arrivé
arrivé